hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
asiatisches rezept und zwei gebackenes
hähnchen es wahrscheinlich schon und hab
es auch bestimmt schon mal auswärts
gegessen aber wenn ich euch jetzt zeigen
wie einfach die zubereitung ist dann
macht ihr das mit sicherheit auch öfter
mal zu hause selber ich hab euch den
vergangenheit schon mal meine gebratene
nudeln gezeigt und meine süße soße
die gibt es heute auch mit dazu und die
videos die verleger ich euch hier unten
in der infobox und jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten die wir für das
heutige rezept benötigen ich bereite
heute zwei ähnlichen brust filets zu das
reicht ungefähr für zwei bis drei
personen je nachdem wie hungrig ihr seid
für den backteig benötigen wir milch
mehl neutrales öl speisestärke
backpulver und etwas salz und für das
fleisch benötigen wir gleich erneut salz
außerdem pfeffer und etwas dunkle
sojasoße und bei mir hat es angefangen
mit 12 13 da hatte ich immer wieder lust
auf gebratenen nudeln mit dem hähnchen
um brauchen sie saurer soße und mit den
jahren habe ich wirklich meine rezepte
perfektioniert und jetzt hat es wirkt
wie original von asiaten nur ohne diese
ganzen geschmacksverstärker und richtig
schön natürliche zutaten wollt müsst ihr
auch was den fleisch ihr verwendet und
können darauf vertrauen für den backtag
gehen jetzt einfach alle zutaten in der
unsere schüssel und verrühren das so
lange bis es richtig schön dickflüssig
wird
[Musik]
und nach wenigen sekunden ist unser
backteig schon fertig und er muss ein
bisschen dickflüssig sein dann ist er
genau richtig und die zutaten verbinden
sich auch besser wenn die milch nicht
ganz aus dem kühlschrank kommen sondern
schon ein bisschen auf zimmertemperatur
gekommen ist jetzt gebe ich das kurz zur
seite und dann bereite ich mal meinen
fleisch worden
jetzt geht's ans fleisch und ich nehm
dafür ist handschuhe gehen natürlich
auch ohne und ihr müsst uns auf jeden
fall in der mitte noch einmal durch
schneiden denn so unsere hähnchenbrust
viel zu dick natürlich ist es auch
wieder alles individuell ich weiß ja
nicht wie eure hähnchenbrust zu hause
ist aber ich zeige euch mal wenn ich so
dick ist dann kann es natürlich sein
dass es innen noch roh ist und außen
eben zu knusprig deshalb weil ich jetzt
einmal in der hälfte durch teilen wir
können auch noch mal drauf klopfen falls
ihr fleisch nicht gleichmäßig sein
sollte
[Musik]
jetzt kommen salz pfeffer und soja sauce
ins spiel wie würzen das fleisch nämlich
direkt an der oberfläche und nicht alles
in der panade die panisch weg auch sofa
knusprig und lecker aber eben die
gewürze kommen direkt aufs fleisch
[Musik]
den geschmack habe ich jetzt hier mit
den händen in das fleisch fein gerieben
quasi könnte auch ein pinsel nehmen aber
ich habe das gefühl mit den händen hat
man immer so ein bisschen mehr gefühl
dafür und jetzt sind sie fertig jetzt
können wir gleich in die panade ein
drucken und dann beraten
für straßen brauchen wir noch neutrales
öl und zwar hoch erhitzt bares ich hab i
rapsöl verwendet können auch gerne
sonnenblumenöl oder anderes verwenden
und gleichzeitig den trick damit ihr
bescheid bist du wann das soweit ist
sobald ihr ein holzstäbchen in euer
verein gibt und der kleine bläschen
aufsteigen dann ist es genau richtig und
ihr könnt anfangen mit eurem fleisch das
ganze gebe ich jetzt einmal in die
panade und dann mag ich das aus für etwa
drei minuten vielleicht auch viel
ihr müsst einfach schon wenn das ganze
schön knusprig ist
[Musik]
nach ca 3 bis 4 minuten ist unser
hähnchen vielleicht auch schon fertig
ich gebe es jetzt etwas küchenpapier
damit es ein bisschen abtropfen kann und
dann schneide ich das ganze an
[Musik]
und jetzt wird das ganze nur noch schön
angerichtet ich habe meine gebratene
nudeln zusammen mit süßsaurer so so
schön vermengt und auch meinen teller
gelegt und jetzt nehme ich mir einmal
ein hähnchen stück und schneidet das in
kleine scheiben gibt dass da drauf und
dann genieße ich das
[Musik]
so meine lieben das ist mein rezept für
das gebackene asiatische hähnchen ich
freue mich sehr wenn ihr das ganze jetzt
nach macht haben und ich lassen uns das
jetzt richtig schön schmecken zusammen
mit den gebratenen nudeln und der
selbstgemachten süß saurer soße
ich verspreche euch ist dauert nicht
lange und es schmeckt viel viel besser
als die gekauften sachen die die man so
bekommt ihr wisst nicht was drin ist und
hier wisst ihr es eben ganz genau macht
gerne nach schickt mir eure fotos mit
dem hashtag iges kitchen auf genau
falls mir dort noch nicht folgt dann tut
das gerne hier sowieso ansonsten könnte
hier auch gerne die glocke aktivieren
dann verpasst ja auch kein video mehr
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten mal wieder einschaltet
[Musik]